from the oscar-nominated film lost in
translation
please welcome Scarlett Johansson
believe it or not I have been wearing
makeup for 35 years no no not really
the art of makeup has been used to
transform performers for centuries and
this award was first introduced in 1981
to honor those of us those who make us
look glamorous or gory or both the
nominees for achievement in makeup are
Richard Taylor and Peter King for the
Lord of the Rings The Return of the King
Edward and regains the 3rd and Yolanda
to sing for Master and Commander the far
side of the world V Neil and Martin
Samuel for Pirates of the Caribbean the
curse of the Black Pearl and the Oscar
goes to Richard Taylor and Peter cane
for the Lord of the Rings for Return of
the King
this is the first Academy Award a
nomination for Peter King this is the
fifth nomination for Richard Taylor
including his nomination and win tonight
the costume design he is won an Oscar
four times
god is scary up here um I just like to
thank the Academy I'd like to thank new
line as I thank Peter
Fran Philippa Barry I like fact all the
team back in New Zealand who worked so
hard for such a long long time I'd like
to thank my gorgeous wife Sarah for
being there every night with a glass of
wine when I got home I thanked my
gorgeous daughter we're just being
gorgeous and Thank You Marjorie Hamelin
domine toh who looked after our onset
prosthetic applications for so many
months
Jason Daugherty who manufactured over
10,000 of those prosthetics to be
applied Gino Acevedo the gentleman
within our company that looked after the
work for so long the cast that had to
wear it all over all those months I
apologize for the rubbery feet and funny
noses but cheers to you all thank you
thank the Academy and Tania Cheers
please welcome Sandra Bullock and John
Travolta
thank you for that John what was the
first movie to ever have sound why sandy
and fellow students that would be Al
Jolson's the jazz singer from 1927 the
first Hollywood film to incorporate both
sound and dialogue I did not know that
well that's why you have to come to
rehearsal
you see I learned many a fun fact by
getting here before my co-presenter
mm-hmm you were early yeah
you were early that's all right okay the
nominees for achievement in sound mixing
are Andy Nelson Annabelle mer and Jeff
Wexler for The Last Samurai
Christopher boys Michael Semin ik
Michael hedges and Hammond peak for the
Lord of the Rings the return of a king
Paul Massey diem Hemphill and Arthur
Rochester for Master and Commander the
far side of the world
Christopher boys David Parker David
Campbell and Lee Orloff for Pirates of
the Caribbean rehearse the Black Pearl
Andy Nelson Annabel mer and Tod Abe
Maitland for Seabiscuit and the Oscar
goes to
Christopher boys my close szymek Michael
hedges and Hammond peak for the Lord of
the Rings return to King
this is the first Academy Award for
Michael semantics Michael Hedges and
Hammond P
Christopher boys is now a three-time
Oscar winner
thank you to the Academy thank you for
the amazing Peter Jackson for an
incredible journey
Barry Osborne Fran Walsh and mark or
dusky everyone at New Line Cinema's
Jodie Levin
Ethan van der Rhine Michael Hopkins
David farmer and the entire sound crew
we couldn't have done it without you my
wife Sherry my three kids
Nicole Jorden and Joseph I love you
thanks yes and I'd like to thank my wife
Joanne and my family and all of the guys
and the team at Park Road post
production back in New Zealand we've
we've done a great thing here especially
soot onsen and John Neil thank you to
the production crew thank you to my wife
and kids and lastly thank you to the
people of New Zealand stand up take a
bow you make us proud yes